so what we have here is a redox
reaction things are getting oxidized and
reduced that's the name
redox but we want to balance this redox
reaction
and when we talk about balancing a redox
reaction we want to
make sure we conserve mass and charge
on both sides of this reaction so how do
we do that
well the first step is to assign
oxidation numbers or
oxidation states to each of the
constituent elements on either
side of the reaction that will know
who's getting oxidized and who's getting
reduced
and then we can set up the half
reactions which we can then balance
all right so let's first look at this
aluminum right over here
it has an oxidation state or an
oxidation number of
zero it's just aluminum by itself
and then we can go to this hydrogen this
is really just a proton right over here
it has a plus one charge and so it's
hypothetical
charge you could say well that would be
plus one as well which would be its
oxidation number or its oxidation state
and then when we get on to the right
side of this reaction
we see that the aluminum now has a
positive three charge so its oxidation
number would also be positive three
and we can see here that the hydrogen
and actually now we have two so
we're gonna have to deal with that later
on we only have one here but now
this hydro each of these hydrogens have
an oxidation number of
zero they're not taking up electrons or
giving away electrons you just
have two hydrogens bonded to each each
other
all right so now that we've assigned
oxidation numbers we can figure out
who's getting oxidized and who is
getting reduced
so if you look at the aluminum aluminum
goes from an oxidation number of zero
to plus three so if your oxidation
number is
increasing that means you're getting
oxidized
oxidized you might also remember oil rig
oxidation is losing electrons because
you're losing electrons you're having a
more positive charge but your oxidation
number is going up so you're getting
oxidized
and if you look at the hydrogen we're
going from a plus one
to a zero if your oxidation number is
reducing
you are being reduced so reduced
so now let's set up both of the half
reactions the oxidized
half reaction for aluminum and then the
reduction for
hydrogen so first for the aluminum we
have an aluminum solid
and it's half reaction it is going to
now a form of aluminum
with a plus three charge in in the
aqueous
state so let's first balance
this for just the number of aluminums we
have we have one aluminum on the left
one aluminum on the right
so that seems balanced now let's try to
balance it for
charge so we have no charge here so we
should have a total of no charge on the
right but we have plus three here
and so what we need to do is add some
electrons
so let me add three
electrons right over here and there we
have it we have
balanced it for charge and now let's
think about
the hydrogen so if we take
we have a proton on the left let me just
do it like this
and it's in an aqueous solution and then
on the right
we just have hydrogen molecules neutral
hydrogen molecules
and so first let us balance it for the
number of hydrogens we have two on the
right
one on the left so we're going to have
to put a two right over here so we've
balanced for the number of hydrogens
and now let's balance for charge
so let's see on the right hand side we
have no
net charge well on the left hand side
right over here we have a positive 2
net charge so in order to balance this i
have to put
two electrons on the left hand side so
let me do that here
so two electrons i'm going to add over
here
and now it looks like it is balanced for
charge now the next thing we want to do
is we want to balance the number of
electrons that we have on the right-hand
side
and on the left-hand side in these half
reactions
and so how can you do that once you have
three here and you have two here
the least common multiple involving a
little bit of your
elementary school mathematics here of
three and two
is six so we can get these both to six
and how could we do that
well we could multiply this top half
reaction
by two so let me do that so if i
multiply this top half reaction
by two and if i multiply this bottom
half reaction
by three why does that work well two
times three electrons is going to give
us six electrons three times two
electrons is going to get us
six electrons and so let me now rewrite
this
so if i multiply by two we're gonna have
two aluminums
so we have two aluminums
in a solid state and then on the right
hand side of this half reaction
i'm multiplying everything by two so now
i have two
aluminums plus three in an
aqueous solution and then i'm
multiplying these electrons by two as
well
so plus six electrons
and now let me do this down here three
times two electrons that is going to
give us
six electrons and then i'm going to
multiply this three times this two so
that's going to give us six
hydrogen protons i guess i could say so
plus
six hydrogen protons that are in an
aqueous
solution and then on the right hand side
if i multiply by three
i have three hydrogen molecules each of
them with two hydrogen atoms
and so now i have balanced the number of
electrons on both
sides and now i'm going to add these two
half reactions and if i add the two half
reactions
what do i get and let me do it down here
so on the left hand side
i'm just going to add up all of this
stuff right over here
so i'm going to get six electrons
plus two aluminums
plus six hydrogen protons plus
six hydrogen protons
and then on the right hand side i am
going to add up
all of this stuff so i have those two
aluminums now with a plus three charge
in an
aqueous solution i'm going to have
the three hydrogens a three hydrogen
molecules i should say
there's actually six hydrogens here and
then i have the six
electrons plus six electrons and i have
six electrons on the left six electrons
on the right i could cancel those
out and then what i have here
is our balanced redox reaction
balanced for both mass and charge
and we are done